hi boys
it's me again just your average girl
look i may be a biological female but
i do hope that just for this video we're
able to converse
as men i want you to think back to 2016
which
i know in internet years is like halfway
between now and the decline of rome
do you like history boys how did rome
fall again was it
the gays tell me all about it back in
the big internet culture war was between
feminists on one side
and men's rights activists on the other
whatever happened to that
these days it says data meme is i don't
know
harambe i did want to do the fedora
though every youtuber who's ever covered
the men's rights movement has done the
fedora and
i wanted to put my own little twist on
it my wardrobe notes for this video say
mri femme fatale and fedora but make it
fashion
school shooter realness i feel like i'm
also serving a little
oh red pilled carmen san diego
in this video i want to ask in all
seriousness
what are we going to do about men
because no offense but
as a group you guys kind of seem like
you're not doing okay
could a group of people who are
purchasing uncooked alpha yogurt
possibly be subsisting in a state of
psychological balance
fellas are regular bowel movements gay
i guess yeah kind of you don't see a
whole lot of psyllium husk in
heterosexual medicine cabinets
i'm losing my target audience here
listen my dudes let's just say
i'm kind of worried about you guys i'm
not saying i'm any better
to be clear i'm not okay either there's
like 15 jars of urine in my refrigerator
right now
yeah that's right women v2 okay get over
it i'm so sorry if this offends your
male notions of feminine delicacy but
i for one will not be shamed by your
patriarchal [ __ ]
you boys you're very rational aren't you
ugh i suppose i was too i admit that
these days rationality
it's something i struggle with both as a
biological female
and as a pisces moon but when i decided
i wanted to make a video for men
contra points i started brushing up on
my reasoning skills because
i want to be so [ __ ] rational
for you so to prepare for this video i
read newton's principia mathematica
wittgenstein's tractatus logical
philosophical and of course
the philosophical classic the rational
male by royal caliente
so my mind is well lubricated and i'm
ready for what i have no doubt will be a
penetrating intellectual
interchange look i want to play by your
rules okay
so there will be no emotions in this
video i will present my arguments in
strict
logical form relying only on facts
reason
evidence and deductive proof
actually you know what [ __ ] that
let's listen to house music and do sex
[Music]
drugs
i'm pandering to the male gays
oh and the male straights
god i love attention hey gorge hey gorge
hey gorge okay i'm ready let's crack
open a cold one boys
my hands are too pretty to open the can
i need a man to do it for me
help [ __ ] it
okay that's super fake orange hey gorge
are there any women still watching this
video
i'm really sorry about all this unless
you're into that sort of thing
in which case how very dare i'm a good
presbyterian and by presbyterian
i do mean pansexual hey how are you look
the video is about men so
i'm trying to be attractive to men am i
doing this right
is this what men like trap straps
it is a risky look for a girl like me
when you do a lingerie look you know
you're going to wind up
somewhere on the front converter violet
trotsky devonte's spectrum
oh but you don't know where exactly and
that
is a dangerous game ladies i have to say
though i actually am feeling
pretty [ __ ] empowered right now but
um
that could be because of the drugs look
gentlemen
let's be rational and we're fooling
around okay part one
oh wait rational axiom one
america's next top victim i think there
is some truth to the idea
that we live in a victimhood culture and
i'm not just talking about campus sjws
with their microaggressions
no [ __ ] this goes all the way to the
top we have white people complaining
about reverse racism we have the literal
one percent
complaining about anti-bridge
prejudice that must be super [ __ ]
hard for you
we have the heterosexual agenda
organizing straight pride parades
you know flaunting their sexuality in
the faces of children who are trying to
raise a family
and protesting in the street like a
bunch of and so of course because there
was women's rights
there has to be men's rights too i've
been hearing about men's rights for my
whole adult life
and i've always been very skeptical
because in my experience
online men's rights activism in practice
always looks like this
women try to do a good thing to solve a
real problem
and then a man shows up to say well what
about men
men also get harassed why aren't you
talking about man
and does this man actually involved in
activism to stop harassment against men
of course he's [ __ ] not he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
he's a troll his contribution to the
conversation
begins and ends with what about man what
about them
honey for this video i decided to
actually do some research for once
and the first thing i did was read the
foundational text of the modern men's
rights movement
which is the myth of male power by
warren farrell actually i listened to
the audiobook because
let's be honest reading is hired but as
i was listening
i admit i thought it made more sense
than i was expecting it to
basically farrell says that second wave
feminists rightly fought against the
traditional gender role that confined
women to domestic servitude
but he argues that the feminist idea
that men have all the power in society
is actually an illusion because the
traditional gender role for men
is just as oppressive he introduces the
idea of male disposability
basically the idea that society values
female lives more than male lives
which are seen as expendable in the
service of protecting and providing for
women and children
and he points to statistics showing that
men make up the majority of military
casualties
workplace fatalities murder victims
suicides and so on so we're supposed to
conclude
that even though at first it looks like
men have more power than women
in fact the queens have a certain kind
of
privilege and being protected and
provided for by the expendable male
worker bees and i guess that
kind of makes sense i feel like i can at
least empathize with the point of view
what i'm saying is i took the red pill
and i rubbed it on my claw
but some initial objections come to mind
like
haven't men been almost all of the kings
presidents and ceos for millennia didn't
men make up all these rules in the first
place
i don't know boys still seems kind of
patriarchal to me
but maybe you'll say that it's only at
the top of society
that men have more power than women
maybe the average man
is also oppressed by the system that
feminists call patriarchy
if that's what you're saying i think i
basically agree
with that see what you have to
understand about me is i'm
such a [ __ ] libra whenever there's a
conflict my gut reaction is to be like
well maybe everybody's right and maybe
there's good points on both sides and we
should all just listen to each other and
rub each other's claws but yo
my scorpio rising persona will not allow
that oh
there will be a champion there will be
blood so
judges how do we decide which gender is
america's next top victim
i mean it's not like you can just change
genders and see how the other half lives
or can you proposition 2
diary of an x-man dear diary
with every false smile i can feel that
on the inside i'm drowning in darkness
mom get out of my room oh you're ruining
my life
look i've never ever talked about this
on my channel before so
this is like a super [ __ ] vulnerable
moment for me but
i was born a boy well was i ever really
a boy
it's hard to say dear diary growing up i
always knew that i was different from
other kids
especially other boys and it took me so
long to pinpoint what it was but there
was this
moment i must have been what seven eight
years old
and i was playing in my parents room all
by myself
and i saw this pair of my mom's shoes
lying on the floor
and i don't know what it was it was like
this magnetism that drew me to them
and i put my little feet in them and
walked in front of the mirror
and i didn't really have the words yet
to describe how i felt
but basically in that moment i
sensed that god had made a mistake and
i was destined to be to be a
cross-dresser
that is super [ __ ] coconuts anyway
then in my 20s my life completely fell
apart and i became a woman hey how are
you
i became one of the dolls my plastic
surgeon is an artist
look boys the point i'm trying to make
here is i used to live your lifestyle
i know what people like you get up to
and i think it's disgusting
i gotta say though since i transitioned
my life has been super [ __ ] great
like
way better now of course a lot of that
is not because women have it better than
men but
because hey gorge i am literally
transgendered
so before i transitioned i was dying
inside you know i was in the wrong body
and now it's like i finally have the
body i was meant to die inside of
but it's not just that i do think that
in some ways
since i started presenting as a woman
people actually do treat me better
i mean they take my opinions less
seriously sure but
that's probably for the best now before
using my personal experience as any kind
of evidence
i guess i should say a couple caveats
caveat one is that
most pre-transitioned trans women are
not like other boys
and most of us we're not living the
business class male experience by
any means you know it's a lot of drunk
melancholics tormented sissies
secretive transvestites poets
you know that sort of thing caveat too
is that my trans experience is not the
trans
experience and i do have a lot of other
privileges that
made things go super [ __ ] well for me
hey how are you don't you just
love it when someone checks their
privilege in a way that's actually
just bragging you know it's super
important for me to acknowledge that
i've been so successful and i've come so
far
in part because i'm white and i'm skinny
and i'm young and i'm blonde
and i'm rich and i pass and i'm educated
and i'm popular and my plastic surgeon
is an artist
and my boyfriend is really rich and hot
and i come from a pure aryan bloodline
and part of what makes me so enlightened
and so compassionate
is that i'm able to recognize these
privileges that i have that
just might not be available to people
who are less fortunate
from the bottom of my [ __ ] at
my father [ __ ] heart that must be
super [ __ ] hard for you i can't even
imagine
what i was saying is there are ways that
people treat me better now that i'm
presenting as a woman
you know people smile at me more i feel
more taken care of
men do things for me now a lot of women
don't like men doing things for them you
know
holding doors helping with luggage
because they feel that it's
infantilizing or condescending
but not me i love it both because i love
attention
and because i'm a recumbent queen who's
too much of a delicate flower to lift a
finger
i do this thing on airplanes where when
it's time for me to put my carry-on
luggage in the overhead bin
i pretend that my bag is too heavy for
me to lift
and then some man will usually get up
and do it for me
even though i'm taller than most men it
makes me happy
another good thing about becoming a
woman is i integrated into female social
groups
and i found that they provide a kind of
communal support and overt affection
that male social groups generally just
don't i find that female social style
suits me better than the male one
which tends to be more atomized more
individualist
where affection is always concealed
behind this semi-jokey
front of competition like think about
the way boys talk to each other when
they play video games
a throne improvement for me has to do
with the way men and women are treated
in public space
when you present female in public you're
more likely to be treated as a
spectacle to be commented upon people
usually men will just blurt out their
opinions about you
sometimes complimentary sometimes
insulting sometimes
just [ __ ] weird whereas when you
present mail in public
you're more likely to be treated either
as invisible or as dangerous
now feminists have traditionally
interpreted these differences as
men asserting dominance over women in
public space
and they've criticized cat calling as
being objectifying degrading and
misogynistic
and it certainly can be all of those
things there's different kinds of cat
calling and i have different feelings
about them
if i'm walking with another woman and a
man says
ladies you look beautiful tonight i
don't know
i like that i think that's nice it makes
me feel seen it makes me feel admired
it boosts my confidence whereas if i'm
walking alone
and a drunk starts following me down the
street singing
have you seen a polythene pam she's so
good looking but she looks like a man
that i am less enthusiastic about
i mean not that that's ever happened i'm
completely [ __ ] unclockable hey how
are you
noah
[Music]
i definitely get where feminists are
coming from because street harassment
sucks i'm a lot more afraid walking
alone at night than i used to be
and there's a lot more places i just
won't go by myself
but on the other hand i do now enjoy
being able to walk down the street at
night
without other people acting afraid of me
i think a lot of feminists have failed
to imagine the ways
that being treated as invisible or
dangerous can
also kind of suck in my video on incels
i talked about male invisibility on
dating apps
and how getting no attention at all can
actually be emotionally worse
than getting a lot of shitty attention
and when it comes to being treated
as dangerous when i was living as a man
sometimes if i was walking at night a
woman on the same block as me
would change sides of the street and i
totally get why
men do scary [ __ ] sometimes and it's
better to be safe
but it's still stung a little bit to be
treated as
dangerous by default i think it can
actually be harmful which
becomes clearer if we add race into the
equation there's ways that white women's
fear
can actually be dangerous in particular
to black men
i had an experience with this recently
when i was filming my video the
apocalypse and i'd rented a room in a
hotel casino
around midnight i was carrying some
camera equipment up to my room
and i got into the elevator with a group
of people from the casino floor
a couple floors up everyone got out of
the elevator except for me
and a single black man well i mean he
was alone
i don't know if he was single that's not
part of the story and as soon as the
door closed
he started literally whistling row row
row your boat
the official melody of performative
innocence and i realized
oh [ __ ] he is afraid that i'm afraid
and i found that just excruciating i was
like oh god
how do other white women behave in
elevators do they like
clutch their purses ugh
that's so funny embarrassing nothing
like that had
ever happened to me when i was living as
a man it's not a thing between black men
and white men
it's a thing between black men and white
women and so that dynamic was there
not just because i'm white and he's
black but because i'm a woman
and he's a man and i thought of that
incident again when i was listening to
the myth of male power
and pharaoh says men's greatest weakness
is their facade of strength
and women's greatest strength is their
facade of weakness
i think there is some truth to the idea
that women's perceived vulnerability can
make them powerful
and men's perceived power can make them
vulnerable now i hope you're taking all
this with a grain of salt because
these are just some little observations
i've made based on a handful of
anecdotes
and as rational males it's important
that we consider
the facts the stats and the figures did
you know
that 46 of men are at least
2.8 times different than 73
of women look it up i haven't i guess my
super [ __ ] libra opinion is that
there's upsides and downsides to male
and female experience
i don't actually think there's a single
definite answer to the vague and useless
question
which gender has it worse i consider
myself a feminist because
i support reproductive rights and i
oppose workplace misogyny
and i generally agree with a lot of the
activism that happens under the heading
of feminism
but i also think a lot of men are just
having a super [ __ ] difficult time
right now and that must be super [ __ ]
hard for them hey are you
and i don't think feminists have an
obligation to care about male x but
i care about you boys god i'm such a
cool girl i think the entire
mid-atlantic region is about to freeze
over
now i'm just a super [ __ ] empathetic
pisces moon and
i really try to understand other
people's pain because
i just find it really really funny
i'm also really really sobering up here
the drugs have worn off
and i'm suddenly feeling
very naked like it's just now occurring
to me that
this is a highly inappropriate outfit
for this occasion
so i'm gonna go put on a robe and
i'll meet you back for the next section
postulate three
the man question
[Music]
hi boys etc etc hey how are you
for the last three years on this channel
i have been your
virgil leading you through gender hell
pickup artists gender dysphoria in cells
radical feminists non-binary genders
men's rights activists
it seems like everybody's having gender
trouble
so what do we make of that well gorge a
very
very rational male philosopher named
hegel once said
that the unfolding of history is a
basically rational process gorge
that means that at any time in history
society is based on certain
principles like um all men are created
equal as long as there's super [ __ ]
rich and white
and there's always contradictions within
those principles which creates
tension and eventually leads to a
rupture like a revolution
where society has to be reorganized
according to new principles
at least i think he was saying something
like that it's pretty hard to make
anything out through the fog of his
unreadable hyper-abstract man-jabbering
god i can't stand that [ __ ]
or any of the other music-hating vol
cells of the male philosophical
tradition
my point is i think our society has
reached a place where gender as we know
it
just isn't working anymore now no one
seems to agree why it isn't working or
how to fix it
but we do all agree that it's broken we
have mainstream feminists saying we need
to continue advancing the rights of
women
we have conservatives saying we need to
restore the gender roles of the 1950s
we have an increasing number of people
not identifying as men or women
we have turfs who think that the
transgenders are the single greatest
threat to civilization
heihou and we have men's rights
activists saying we need a male
equivalent to feminism
to liberate men from their oppressive
gender role now i want to focus on that
last one
because in principle i agree i've spent
a lot of the last three years covering
the manosphere i know such a feminine
topic loves that for me
and from all the time i've tortured
myself wading through these communities
of in-cells
pickup artists men's rights slacktivists
intellectual dark web fanboys and
alt-right racists
i've noticed that they all have one
thing in common which is that they all
recruit from the same
massive pool of sad young men we all
know the archetype
he has trouble relating to women he has
no strong friendship group he's not
excited about any long-term goals
and he fills the void with video games
and porn and just to clarify
i'm not trying to take away your video
games in porn i'm not telling you what
to do with your penis
you can rub one out to this video for
all i care just don't pull a gamer keyed
on me okay
i live in fear look i like to believe
that until the red pillars inject their
poison
most of these boys are not bad people i
think all of this originates in a
genuine crisis of male identity and i
think it's happened in
something like the way men's rights
activists describe the sacrificial role
of men as warriors
is no longer widely glorified or
necessary the traditional protector
provider role of men
is being replaced by a more equal and
undefined gender dynamic
and college professors and activists are
telling men that most of our culture's
aspirational representations of manhood
are toxic and bad but without an
attractive replacement vision of
aspirational manhood
average young men can only envision
their future as
what the beta the [ __ ]
the new male and in a post-left-tube
internet we're so used to laughing at
this vocabulary and to be fair it is
very funny but we forgot especially us
grylls
that for a lot of men these words
actually do tap into a deep
existential angst and a lot of leftists
go well how can men be so angsty
especially white men they're so
privileged but existential angst
is often a disease of privilege if
you're actually being oppressed
you have a struggle you have something
to fight for and therefore
a purpose but for a lot of men their
lack of purpose puts them in search
of a struggle and that along with the
loneliness and the lack of a positive
identity
is what makes men vulnerable to
recruitment by the manosphere groups
and by the alt-right and even worse it
seems to be a motivating factor for the
small but growing number of young men
who decide to pick up a gun and open
fire in a shopping center
there were two mass shootings during the
weekend i was writing this video
resulting in 31 deaths both shooters
were young white men
and one of them posted about the
shooting on an alt-right image board now
i don't pretend to fully understand the
motives of mass shooters
but i don't think it's a coincidence
that basically all of them are men
one possible interpretation of the mass
shooting epidemic
is that these killers are trying to
resurrect some horrible
parody of ancient masculine glory and
therefore
to be seen and recognized as men
by unleashing homeric violence in a
[ __ ] walmart
and of course there's also the racism of
the alt-right killers
and the wounded sexual entitlement of
the incel killers
but that racism and that sexual
entitlement are learned
and men in the throes of a masculinity
crisis are more receptive to learning it
so you can try to take down their forums
and ban their accounts and de-platform
their events
but as long as this male identity crisis
goes on
i don't see any end to these problems
theorem four
what do there is this median narrative
that has emerged around me and around
this
channel and by the way the fact that
there's any kind of media narrative
about this channel
is super [ __ ] coconuts because let's
be real gorge
i just wanted to pour milk on my face
and talk about the mouth feel but
there's this immediate narrative that my
role in the discourse is de-radicalizing
young alt-right men and it's true
that if you read the leftist youtube fan
subreddits i used to be alt-right posts
are so common they're considered cliche
and some of them cite me as an influence
in changing their politics which
i love for them and i'm super very happy
about it but
it's also a lot of responsibility
they're my boys and i worry about
my boys because in reality it's not like
they go from far-right extremists to
complacent centrists
no most of them go far left a lot of
them become communists or anarchists
so i watch them go from far to my right
to significantly to my left
it's not really de-radicalizing so much
as re-radicalizing and i think it's
definitely an
improvement but i still worry it's not
going to be enough
i worry about my boys because i don't
think that the left yet has
a final solution to the man question oh
no
that was worded poorly you know there's
kind of two options the left has for
disillusioned
men the first is the marxist promise of
economic revolution
we say well actually yes you are
oppressed but you're oppressed because
of your class
not your gender so just join the
revolution it's gonna be super [ __ ]
crazy
we're gonna overthrow the bourgeoisie
meow meow smash
no voting and then things will be better
for you
now i think that has a couple
limitations one
is that i look at the far left and i see
a bunch of people who spend all their
time accusing each other of abusing
moderator privileges in closed facebook
groups
and i'm concerned that might not succeed
at ending capitalism meow meow
like definitely vote for bernie sanders
or elizabeth warren or whoever but
if you're investing all of your hopes in
a capital r revolution
i worry that can become like waiting for
godot or waiting for the rapture
so we do need political change but i
feel like i'm
failing my boys if i'm somehow giving
them the idea that
revolution is their only hope because
here's the other thing
even if we did succeed ending capitalism
there would still be gender
and my boys would still need some model
of what it is to lead a good life as a
man
now the other option the left has for
disillusioned men is
the feminist tranquilizer we say look
toxic masculinity is the reason you
don't have room to express your feelings
and it's the reason you feel lonely and
inadequate so while feminism tells women
you hate your body and you're constantly
doubting yourself because society
did this to you and needs to change we
kind of just tell men
you're lonely and suicidal because
you're toxic stop it
we tell them they're broken without
really telling them how to fix
themselves
i think what we need is a new positive
ideal of manhood
which i don't think is something that
women can create for men
even if they wanted to and honestly the
best way for that to happen
may actually be some kind of men's
movement but on the left the whole idea
of a men's movement is basically
taboo because the men's movement we all
know is basically just a backlash to
feminism
and at worst it's just straight up
misogyny
and look boys i understand that being
lectured about man spreading for most of
was super [ __ ] hard for you and
you're still mad about it but
posting endless outrage porn about false
rape accusations and paternity fraud
isn't actually gonna make life any
better for you because yes
those things are horrible when they
happen but they're not systemic
issues that affect most men i think what
would actually improve
life for most men is a positive ideal of
21st century manhood
but that's not something i can give to
you because in case you hadn't noticed
i'm literally a [ __ ] woman i can't
mom you through this one boys you're on
your own
you have to help each other so find each
other in the comments section
meet up on reddit make friends clean
your room
leave the house [ __ ] each other i don't
know
it's worth a try and failing that
you could always throw in the towel and
become a woman
worked for me
[Music]
so
just trying to give like a lady energy
yeah it is it's very it is english it's
very john mcclane very quentin
crisp very aristocrat super [ __ ]
naked right now that's crazy
that's super [ __ ] crazy uh according
to traditional gender roles
men are useful for their labor and women
are useful for their wounds
well i'm a woman without a womb so i
guess i'm useless
but i'm beautifully useless ah i'm a
work of art
the problem with our society is we've
turned men into women
it's disgusting as an ally to men
it's not my place to speak for them or
speak over them but
i just want to use my platform to
uplift some male voices who
might not have as many subscribers as me
i'm not hypergamous i don't need a rich
husband
if i make what share i don't need a rich
man
i am a rich man it's not even really
much of an insult being called a
delusional man
many great books have been written by
so bad i'm bad
i'm really bad okay